is the hottest movie it's the biggest
franchise people love it so much
what kind of
Moxie sets in you for that one
so yeah great I mean I I kind of I I was
always very Vain about driving cars in
films I was thought I was like really
good at it and and so so when the Fast
and Furious franchise sort of started up
I thought oh how fun to be in a movie
where all you do is drive cars that'd be
so cool
um so I bumped into van at a party
um I didn't really know him but I went
up was that the night you danced with
him in the rain no no that's okay by
then I knew him okay well but you know
and no this was at a party I didn't know
him at all he didn't know me and I I did
that I did that you know fangirl thing
big time I sort of went and said oh I
think you're wonderful Mr Diesel
um
I feel so much better about the way I
live my life now go on
um and you know gosh I would so love to
be in one of your movies with you I was
I was Shameless it was embarrassing
really and uh and you know that
beautiful voice that's like cross
between bra Brown melted brown sugar and
honey and Maleficent gorgeous gorgeous
everything that's gorgeous you know you
know the oh hell and you know yeah I
can't do it and I can't do it at all but
um
but he you know he made a little space
for me in his movies I was very thrilled
about well and you're in the new one too
yes I am I mean it's so exciting that's
going to be the hottest movie does it
make you feel hot to be in those movies
I I love the variety I'm not sort of
snooty about being the lead role or
anything like that it's lovely when I am
but I'm happy to service a film in a
different way I've always thought since
I was young that that person with the
most range was always the most sexy uh
desirable the one I would be the most
enamored with and
you've got so much rain the range girl
like Mrs range speaking of 1923 the
prequel the Yellow Stone I mean this is
once again
signed for the sequel yes you're coming
back that's how phenomenal it was
everybody was on the feeder we have a
clip roll it please
what does that say about us as a species
we've been married for 40 years 44. okay
I'm rounding down to make us feel
younger well that's not working these
are all those years you've never asked
me a question that you did not have the
answer to uh
I have an answer I know care to hear it
I can't wait
it'll be the thing that ends us
greed will be the thing that kills us
all
when I see that clip I just think what a
star Harrison is honestly Harrison holds
the screen in a way that is quite
absolutely magical I find well um so do
you well I don't know but I see right
there I'm I'm just in awe of Harrison
basically
[Music]